a video shows world leaders laughing
about President Trump behind his back
although they may just be laughing at
the voters who elected him
[Music]
well isn't that adorable the tour guides
at Epcot Center hang out off-duty
just a few regular working stiffs
shooting the breeze how cute now Trump
is hit back calling Trudeau two-faced
which is a step up from being
black-faced he should be red-faced but
Trump should be pissed at all all
employees talk about their boss behind
their back and really in world affairs
Trump's their boss and their middle
managers operating franchises under his
watchful eye they don't talk behind the
backs of inconsequential jerks
so Trudeau still has nothing to worry
about I mean just watch this back and
forth are you remember we talked about
is 70% increase over these past years in
the coming years including we
significant investments in our fighter
jets significant investments in our
naval fleets we are increasing
significantly our defense spending from
previous governments that cut okay where
are you now in terms of your number
little boy you see that it was like an
episode of Celebrity Apprentice world
leaders edition and you saw how obedient
the contestant was Trump really should
have given him a cookie or some shoe
polish instead Trump just handed him his
car keys and told him to bring the limo
out front but that's life every boss
good and bad as employees that talk
about him or her it's a necessary
function that unites underlings who need
to vent when the big kahuna isn't around
and that's the burden of being the Big
Kahuna but at the end of that silly day
after schooling these cheapskates over
money they've owed and responsibilities
they've ignored he really still is the
boss who works for us and not them I
have to say Emily I found the two-faced
joke by Trump to be genius because it
made you think that Trudeau is literally
two-faced he definitely did not shy away
from taking it face to face yeah no pun
intended
um and I think as the media is focusing
on this
the the childish aspect of what these
world leaders did the reality is that
that summit was a success for us yes yes
and in general for the entire NATO
alliance it was a big deal that our one
backed away from his threat to stop the
increased defense spending towards the
Baltic States in Poland it's a big deal
that 29 all 29 member states came
together basically against Russia to
increase that spending and it's a big
deal I think that Trump got that
commitment towards that increased money
and with that more conciliatory tone
conciliatory tone as wopo put it when up
until now everyone's been kind of
blasting him for saying oh you're just
threatening all the other states so I
think that this kind of represents a new
and improved NATO and a new and improved
approach to it um but you know we're
getting a lot of let's go back let's go
back to his response yes to face right
three faced all right white in red wait
a minute wait a minute I reason I'm so
curious about this is everybody says hey
you Democrats you're such snow flakes
now who's the snow flake now talk about
overly sensitive detectors he's white
the pressure all I could my face the
president the president should not be
taking everything so personally he
represents I know he's the one who's
bonded with the two-faced comment that
disguise oh no look it seems to me that
he doesn't understand they can say all
they want he's still the leader of the
free exactly a leader that way right but
he reacts as if oh this is all about me
no I thought that was a great response
because it brings back the whole Cocteau
so he's always going to create more
animosity going for with people that
slides on your overhyping it no body
difference they weren't making fun of
them they were gossiping of yes yes you
gossip as you say or mail around to
people
you got some about your boss and
celebrity it happens both all the time
you should hear what they say about mrs.
yes I got your office wired he does what
he wants and they have to react to it
yeah if they're living in his world if
Trump wants to take 40 minute questions
they have to sit there like little boys
and do it he was complaining that he was
late for cocktails now I understand that
we've all been there he needs a drink
scandal the point is is it there at his
mercy yeah and he is the boss picked up
on this seriously as I think I think
it's I think it's an efficient ad but it
really is the world is not just laughing
at Trump laughing at America is with
that ads saying well and if mines gonna
capitalize on that and he talks a lot
about his foreign policy chops and
people who are supporters of him do you
have to remember he has two former
defense secretaries Madison gates
that have both talked about how not good
he was at foreign policy Gates said this
he said he was wrong on nearly every
foreign policy and national security
issue in the past four decades talking
about Biden if they want to go there by
the way politifact not super
conservative
rated gates quote mostly true yeah on
the way that they're assessing Biden so
they're if he wants to go foreign policy
I think he needs to be prepared that
there will be plenty of critics who come
after him the Obama administration a lot
of the foreign policy decisions that
they made but I think if you ask
Tillerson and Madison the incumbent not
such nice you know what want asked
Baghdady
oh yeah I think yeah you know what ask
the dog
I think the problem I think that what
them you know the media grabbed this
story because none of the people in the
media are used to being managers or
bosses they're all journalists so they
don't donate when you manage anything
there are people in the mailroom and
where else that we'll talk about but you
have you gone overseas and realize that
most of the world doesn't understand
Trump I love that I don't I don't want
to be moved by mr. popular scared of him
I don't think this was the reaction to
Obama I don't think even even there were
they had their way with oh yeah right
you know what you were probably laughing
when he was bowing to the savvy kid I
remember people threw a shoe at George W
but they would never laugh done yet and
you know what he dodged it like a pro by
me right in the eye
oh my god she is Dana got a black eye